If your man or woman does not share locations with you,
then you should be worried.
Okay? Cause I cannot think of a single reason
why I would not share my location with my partner
or anyone that I care about.
All of my friends, family,
they all have my location.
And it's usually for safety reasons. Honestly.
Sometimes it's for snooping.
I'm sure it's fine. We all do it. Okay?
Never. Because we don't trust each other.
If your partner refuses to share locations with you.
Kind of sus a little sketch.
What are they doing? Know so many people are torn on this,
but I will die on this hill
if they refuse to share locations with you after you've asked.
Little suspicious.